[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
sujets qui font l'actualité au 12
janvier près de 190 mille personnes sont
aujourd'hui vaccinées en france la
campagne a débuté le 27 décembre dernier
dans le pays des communes proposent des
structures
les annonces gouvernementales se
multiplient on fait aujourd'hui le point
sur la stratégie vaccinale dans les
yvelines avec nos trois invités ils sont
ce soir tous les trois ans vision
joséphine coleman berger maire de
plaisir bonsoir le docteur lourd à base
d'arm vice président de l'ordre des
médecins des yvelines est médecin
urgentiste à versailles bonsoir et le
docteur olivier pajot médecin référent
infectiologie dans les y viennent pour
le groupe vivalto santé
bonsoir alors je le disais dans les
titres la campagne de vaccination a
débuté le 27 décembre dernier dans les
yvelines la toute première s'est faite
dans les pas de mon repos à sartrouville
pour les professionnels de santé ça a
commencé le 4 janvier au sein du centre
hospitalier de versailles
eléonore sino caissier rendu regardez
c'est le premier du département il est
ouvert depuis lundi est déjà plébiscité
le centre de vaccination du centre
hospitalier de versailles accueille les
professionnels de la santé
de plus de 50 ans pour leur administrer
le vaccin faizal heures contre le coït
disent nous on a mis un pied dans la
porte
entre dimanche soir et lundi on a
énormément depuis lundi en 48 heures on
a vacciné plus de 300 personnes donc à
la fois des hospitaliers mais aussi des
professionnels de santé libéraux
c'est un dispositif qu'on a mis en place
main dans la main avec le conseil de
l'ordre de 78 l'aptahr la plateforme
territoriale d'appui avec le soutien de
la r
ce qui va probablement évoluer dans le
temps en fonction des besoins en
fonction des demandes
tous les après midi de 13h30 à 16h30 une
salle de réunion fait donc office de
centre de vaccination
une dizaine de personnels de l'hôpital
médecins pharmaciens et infirmières se
chargent de la permanence et accueil
leurs confrères qu'ils soient salariés
de l'hôpital ou bien le libéro c'est un
grand jour
voilà je suis très content parce que je
pense que c'est la seule solution pour
s'en sortir
le coc vie 19 et commence à durer et
et c'est pour que ça s'arrête aussi pour
que qu'on s'en débarrasse quoi tout
simplement
en plus de son centre de vaccination
propre le centre hospitalier de
versailles est chargée de la
distribution des doses de vaccins dans
tout le département
la distribution se fait pour tous les
centres publics et privés du département
au départ de notre pharmacie avec
nécessité de maintenir la chaîne du
froid durant le transport
à savoir à 4 degrés une fois sorti du
congélateur une stabilité de cinq jours
à 4 degrés depuis le début de la
campagne de vaccination le département
des yvelines compte un peu plus de 500
personnes vaccinées et pad inclut un
chiffre qui devrait augmenter plus
rapidement avec l'ouverture prochaine
d'autres centres de vaccination sur le
territoire alors au 12 janvier c'est
plus de 40000 franciliens qui ont été
vaccinés parmi les publics prioritaires
docteur de bastard j'aimerais commencer
avec vous est-ce qu'il ya moyen de faire
rapidement le point sur les yvelines
alors le point sur la vaccination en
effet elle a commencé lundi dernier il
ya une semaine à l'hôtel hélios comme
des délits dans votre reportage ça s'est
fait en coordination orphelinat depuis
les mobilisations
parce que comme vous a pas échappé il ya
eu un changement stratégique en avant
afin que les janvier et à et donc
pendant ces vacances tout et s'est
mobilisée pour mettre en place cette
excitation qui était réservé doublé au
départ uniquement aux ehpad et à et qui
finalement s'est étendue aux
professionnels de santé
rapidement donc dès le lundi qui était
le jour de rentrée s'est mis en place
sur l'hôpital qui va rester le mot quota
mignot qui est le sens de référence est
ce qu'on appelle le le
congélo porter c'est à dire l'endroit où
sont acheminés les vaccins qui offre une
sélection des vaccins vers 16h à
airaines pour lequel il doit en commun
trial et qu'on paiera tueur de moins 80
degrés donc c'est à cet endroit que sont
stockés les payx malchance une
distribués sur les autres centres de
vaccination a beaucoup de la minuad et
lundi derniers vacciner un grand nombre
de professionnels de santé à la demo et
hospitaliers médecins infirmières et il
y avait en elle il y avait une forte
mobilisation des professionnels des
premiers jours pour ce faire matinée
aujourd'hui les chiffres quand on est
plus grasse et elles un sillage 3d des
personnages ont été vaccinés sont des
professionnels de santé
parce qu'ils sont en effet extrêmement
exposées avec de contamination et puis
il ya une hausse
le maître mot c'est que ce vaccin lui
tend les bras je tiens technologue en
dira presque puisque c'est une
spécialiste d extrêmement contaminant
donc au sein d'une famille les paravents
vous avez une personnalité attaquez vous
voyez finalement qu'il avait l'ordre et
réhabiliter d'un dessin matin là on sait
que s'il ya une personne qui atteint
toute l'airé millet est vraiment atteint
donc quand vous avez un soignant qui a
qui atteint ils risquent de contaminer
l'ensemble de la communauté à médical de
santé et donc m finalement sur la touche
et répit à une unité un service
il va falloir protéger ses personnels et
donc c'est par le vaccin
on peut les paul est protégée qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils désignent ou de
véhicules nationale c'est la plus grande
partie de ceux qui sont vaccinés et vous
citiez le docteur pages aux que du côté
de vivalto santé ça a débuté le 15
janvier dans les yvelines
on est aujourd'hui à 277 vaccination
d'octobre à juin qu'est ce que ça
représente sur le nombre de praticiens
et ce qu'il en reste encore à vacciner
chez vous bien écouté alors oui il en
reste encore ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que la stratégie initiale qui
avait été développé par notre ars
d'ile-de-france et de vacciner les
soignants de plus de 50 ans
éventuellement de moins de 50 ans avec
les comorbidités qui exposent à des
formes graves donc on a essayé bien sûr
de respecter cette cette consigne est ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'on a
identifié nous dans le groupe un peu
plus de 500 agents ont dit comme ça ce
qui comprend des soignants médecins que
mon médecin d'ailleurs où percent
administratives de plus de 50 ans et que
actuellement comme vous le disiez on est
un petit peu plus de 77 maintenant
vaccination mais il faut le dire avec
aussi des vaccinations de personnes de
moins de 50 ans parce que parfois il
faut finir de flacons à l'objectif c'est
aucune doses de ce vaccin ne doit être
gâchée et donc tout personnel il finit
qui souhaitent être vaccinés pu
bénéficier peut bénéficier de la
vaccination
donc oui un mouvement il ya il ya un
engouement chez les soignants qui est
tout à fait remarquable qui est pour
l'instant essentiellement et c'est
factuel chez les médecins
mais qui je crois est suivi parce que
les discussions de couloirs me le montre
par rapport à tous les soignants et
vraiment je crois que les gens ont très
envie à la fois de se protéger eux mais
en se vaccinant aussi de protéger les
autres
la revoir un engouement du côté des
praticiens vous le dites il y a aussi
les français qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner puis on voit des villes qui se
mobilisent et qui montrent une envie de
prêter des locaux c'est le cas notamment
de joséphine kama ce berger à plaisir
vous informer sur les réseaux sociaux le
6 janvier dernier être en mesure
d'accueillir un centre au sein de votre
palais des sports où est-ce que ça en
est et pourquoi vous proposé de prêter
un équipement municipal
mais ok je crois que l'engouement dont
on parlait est réel tous les jours
j'aperçois des personnes je rencontre
des personnes qui me disent l'envi
qu'ils ont de se faire vacciner ce qui
n'était pas le cas il ya encore quelques
semaines donc je sais que bien sûr les
lieux qui ils vont être homologué on va
dire pour être vacciné vont être
décidées bien sûr par la grèce par
l'état c'est pas les vies qui vont
décider mais en tout cas il faut que
nous
nous étions je dirais en ordre de marche
et de capacité de pouvoir accueillir
éventuellement bien sûr des centres de
vaccination pour aller encore plus vite
alors je sais bien qu'avec le vaccin
files heure s'est compliqué pour toutes
les raisons que les gens connaissent sur
sur cette problématique de conservation
on espère avoir un autre vaccin comme au
ghana pour pouvoir accompagner toutes
ces démarches là et bien sûr sur plaisir
mais je pense pas être la seule le maire
dans cette démarche là de pouvoir ouvrir
un centre qui pourrait être efficace
auprès de la population qui est très
attendu et puis d'autres pas nous avons
pris contact avec des médecins et des
soignants sur la ville de plaisir qui
serait aussi également partant dans la
mesure du possible et qu'une
autorisation officielle est bien de
participer à cette vaccination de plus
grande envergure dans quelques semaines
oui justement vous disiez il ya des
villes comme coignières qui propose des
infrastructures ou des personnels au
niveau de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines se serait
possiblement le vélodrome qui
deviendrait un centre de vaccination
en discutant avec certains élus on nous
a confié qu'il y aurait peut-être des
difficultés d'approvisionnement au sein
du département docteur de basta est ce
que c'est une réalité
ou est-ce que c'est lié à des chiffres
de la coved de la densité de population
est ce que quelle est la situation de ce
côté là alors en effet on échange
plusieurs fois par jour avec la grèce on
peut pas donner toute l'information
c'est la grèce qui va les donner
il ya en effet enfin je partage pas ce
que dit mon berger puis et puis le 2e
temps pageau s'est il ya un énorme
engouement des professionnels jusqu'aux
halles est admis que tout le monde
essaie de devoir passer voir être excité
mais on est venu nous conduirons se
restreint à ce que les autorités c'est à
dire l'état de santé de cinq ans
hop mais c'est pas mal les personnes de
taille dans la santé ils sont avec des
comorbidités le ya en effet pour
l'instant sion ce type de vaccin qui est
un peu complexe parce que voilà savez
c'est moins 80 et c'est compliqué il ya
eu à près de 180 structure ou emule qui
se seront portés projet c'est entre cinq
des six nations
malheureusement il n'y a pas
suffisamment mettra en maître sur tous
les sites et souffre toutes les mines
spect est si important secure n'est en
effet les municipalités et qu'ils se
soient proposées et à travers respecter
leur set mais c'est à dire les communes
connaissent les personnes âgées qui
habitent short et toi on prenne ce point
au quotidien avec leurs lances et c est
ce qu est pourquoi les amener vers les
centres de référence c'est bien les sens
qui sont vous avez ôté saint quentin par
exemple le vélodrome et à nous payer par
une coordination entre le ccas de
plaisir le ccas de la ville vers corte
le centre de vaccination de saint
quentin et les gens seront aidés ou un
train sq richard des agendas type de
public pour tuer dans les créneaux et
les doses que quand on dispose et le
ccej le plaisir va aider parfois
l'acheminement des patients sur nexans
de vaccination et des gens seront
vaccinés pas la légende 64 ans mais la
même façon moi or il y aura des gens
diront 74 ans et demi est ce qu'on peut
réfectionner moi c'est compliqué mais là
aujourd'hui
pfizer moderna d'averna kibaki qui
consomme exceed avec modern art sont des
vaccins de t-pain c'est compliqué mais
comme vous l'avez vu le vaccin a asséné
quatre et un autre mode de vaccins anti
cubaine mais rapidement sur le enfin
valoir une autorisation de mise sur le
marché
il est propre et en les jours une aile
et là ça permettra une destination qui
prospère dans les cabinets qui sera avec
une ambition plus cher va permettre de
thaksin et à sorman mais dès aujourd'hui
vous avez vu le nom de next un poids
relativement important ils nous montrent
façon constante bien sûr et voilà il
faut être aux petits c'est moi je le
suis vous disiez aussi voilà lé les gens
demandent à se faire vacciner nous on a
voulu savoir ce que pensaient les saint
quentinois de tout ça le micro et tendu
par patrick jacques de dixmude
moi je veux vraiment que les
vaccinations déjà avance vite et bien
sûr j'y crois parce que je viens du
milieu médical
donc clairement je suis pour et il faut
que ça avance quand même un bain pour
pas attraper locaux vides et est
beaucoup plus tranquille d'esprit et je
pense que la vaccination est sécurisé
donc pas de soucis dont les yvelines je
n'ai pas particulièrement mais moi je
peux vous dire que on et comment en
france j'en ai toujours en retard dans
métro un jeu choix pour les masques
n'avait pas mal de maintien se faire
vacciner donc en a plus en plus
confiance alors notre journaliste a
aussi rencontré des personnes réticentes
mais qui n'ont pas souhaité répondre
face à la caméra et c'est une question
que nous avons aussi posée à nos
téléspectateurs chaque semaine nous
faisons un sondage on va le voir à
l'écran c'est la réponse oui qui arrive
en tête sur fait on souhaite accélérer à
la vaccination notamment dans les villes
on sait qu'il ya des régions qui ont
accéléré cette vaccination à nancy
notamment les plus que soit la
vaccination des plus de 75 ans a débuté
laurent de vesta est ce qu on pourrait
aussi voir s'accélérer certaines petites
choses mais bien sur la stratégie et les
deux
bac si nallet et s'adaptant s adapte à l
épidémie à l'évolution d'épidémie on l'a
vu c'est ce qu'on disait ou des vacances
de noël avant les réveillons où
finalement la stratégie évolue et donc
voit qu'elle s'accélère beaucoup puisque
or on peut penser ici la fin du mois de
janvier
la vaccination va être étendu à d'autres
des personnes d'autres points centraux
pas dire je pense que malgré tous les
reniements la lrs sanac des fonds assez
empirique et pragmatique par rapport à
l'évolution de l'épidémie
encore une fois c'est va nous permettre
de nous en sortir c'est quand cette
excitation pour les 50 ans et je suis
ravi d'avoir pu être vaccinés comme je
suis médecin urgentiste
je vais prendre un gros soulagement
parce que tous les jours on voit des
patients réactions turques au vide on
est vu comme à son confrère qui ont été
atteints certains qui sont décédés deux
cortèges qui travaille pour bobby
bateaux et de l'europe
comme tous les établissements privés et
publics le monde a joué le jeu
pour moi cette première vague et la
deuxième au monde a été vraiment
extrêmement investi exploit b et a
heureux ceux qui ont pu bénéficier de
cette vaccination de de pouvoir être
protégés comme ça parce que il ya il ya
eu les morts parce que j'ai toujours été
les mythes sur un sujet il des morts
mais j'ai réussi beaucoup d'entre eux
sont malades est bon un certain nombre
sont pas bons encore aujourd'hui cible
il ya des atteintes
ils sont pas la peine en tous les cas
ils sont pas comme tous comme moi qu'ils
étaient avant d'avoir été le pays
d'accueil
donc je pense que c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important comment sélectionner
pour la grippe on sait que la ville de
belgrade
et puis ça permet de protéger les autres
et moqueuse et c'est un geste altruiste
aussi et puis ça permet de ne pas être
malade pas voir les complications qu'on
peut avoir avec la grippe est là avec ce
qui donne accès à cette vaccination il
ya encore deux semaines selon un sondage
ipsos la france était la championne du
monde des pays réfractaires à ce vaccin
seulement 40% des français acceptait de
se faire vacciner olivier pajot est ce
que vous ressentez
cette réticence même du côté des
professionnels de santé ou maintenant de
la campagne a commencé on sait que le
vaccin pourrait nous permettre de sortir
de cette crise sanitaire
oui la réticence elle existe et c'est
tout à fait ce que j'avais à dire c'est
à dire qu'il ya un paradoxe si on
parlait tout à l'heure dans le moment et
il existe il est certain et je crois que
en chef de file il ya les médecins
effectivement comme disait le reportage
beaucoup de médecins sont fait vacciner
ce qui rassure d'une certaine façon les
autres soignants est probablement la
population générale mais il ya des
personnes qui se posent des questions et
je crois que dans la stratégie vaccinale
global ce sur quoi il faut insister
c'est évidemment les sujets techniques
l'organisation pratique mais
probablement aussi la l'information
prendre le temps d'expliquer aux gens le
les deux questions qui reviennent le
plus souvent et qui inquiète et y
compris des soignants c'est comment at
on pu fabriquer un vaccin en une année
seulement - même qu'une année et qu'est
ce que c'est que ce nouveau vaccin arn
dont on ne sait pas grand chose alors
les réponses on peut les donner là elles
sont assez simple quand tous les
laboratoires de recherche du monde
travaille en même temps sur un sujet
dans un vaccin est développé en moins
d'un an plus tôt que dans quelques
années ça c'est la première réponse et
puis le vaccin à rennes en réalité ça
fait une dizaine d'années que c'est
c'est connu et c'est même éprouvé mais
dans d'autres indications qui sont à la
cancérologie donc les réponses on les a
mais ce temps de l'explication de la
pédagogie que l'on doit faire et y
compris auprès des soignants il est il
est absolument fondamental et il doit
absolument intégrer dans la dans la
stratégie de communication parce que je
pense que même si les intentions qu'on
voit sont 76% des personnes qui veulent
se faire vacciner dans les faits n'est
pas sûr qu'on atteigne ce chiffre là si
on fait pas cette information qu'on doit
à toutes ces femmes comme nazir j'ai
justement tant qu'élu local quel est le
ressenti
de vos administrés est ce qu il ya de
l'inquiétude au contraire est-ce qu'on
vous appelle vous sollicite beaucoup en
disant pourquoi nous toujours pas
pourquoi sûr plaisir il n'y a pas non
non rien pour nous comme je le disais
effectivement aujourd'hui bien il ya un
engouement mais je rejoint également le
docteur qui gagnent parlé en disant que
nous avons malgré tout un rôle à jouer
en tant qu'élus nous avons un rôle à
jouer d'information est aussi savoir
rassurer alors on n'a pas la pédagogie
aussi fois tu que vous bien sûr les
médecins mais on est capables nous même
d'avoir dix-huit change avec à la fois
les parents d'élèves les seniors qui
sont dans nos collectivités et qu'ils
peuvent encore avoir quelques réticences
donc à partir de là on ressent malgré
tout ces derniers et ces derniers jours
parce qu'il ya eu aussi des vaccinations
de médecin parce qu'il ya eu des
vaccinations puise en nombre eh bien il
ya eu effectivement un mouvement on le
sent qui rassure et des personnes du
magal et moi je reçois des coups de fil
personnel puisque beaucoup de plaisir
wahou mon numéro de téléphone et donc
ils m'appellent pour savoir comment ils
vont être vaccinés
quand ils peuvent s'inscrire donc on
s'aperçoit que malgré tout l'information
est passée et que la confiance dans nos
scientifiques et nos médecins est
vraiment là on a pu constater au niveau
de l'ehpad à plaisir ou également
puisqu'on est en lien avec l'hôpital de
ghafsai on est aussi dans la vaccination
actuellement des malades des personnes
âgées et aussi des soignants et tout ça
fait que le bouche à oreille fonctionne
et qu'il y a je dirais une ambiance
rassurante alors maintenant ce le fait
d'être rassurés fait qu' il y à une
pression très forte pour qu'on aille
beaucoup plus vite et donc c'est pour
cela je crois que nous les élus locaux
on doit regrouper et on doit aussi
entendre que nous pouvons être un lien
est un moyen aussi de faciliter et
d'accélérer
cette vaccination qui maintenant passe
dans le registre de la confiance et
c'est un bosseur de monde sur cette
question de confiance en gaza en
décembre il y avait 200 élus locaux qui
signent un manifeste pour appeler les
maires à saint maxin et pour donner
l'exemple
on trouvait karl olive le maire de
poissy il alexandra rosetti maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux film guiguen mer
des clayes sous bois ou encore pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental des yvelines vous madame
coleman ce verger est ce que vous seriez
prête à vous faire vacciner pour montrer
l'exemple
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr je m'étais
inscrite également dans cette liste pour
pour montrer l'exemple en même temps est
ce que est ce qu'on est obligé de le
mettre en scène le fait de se faire
vacciner je ne sais pas à ça c'est autre
chose mais en tout cas de me faire
vacciner certainement
je ne veux pas la prendre la place de
qui que ce soit donc aujourd'hui je vais
attendre mon tour et puis bien sûr je
serai au milieu des plaisirs oit pour me
faire vacciner comme tout le monde et
j'en serai ravi vraiment parce que
rappelons le il ya un calendrier il va
bouger encore le 18 janvier puisque la
vaccination pour les plus de 75 ans et
les personnes présentant une fragilité
particulière qui ne sont pas un résident
des pâtes et pourront se faire vacciner
ça sera peut-être le cas dès lundi à
dans la ville de versailles puisqu'elle
compte ouvrir un centre au gymnase
richard mique l'euro de bastard la
population de plus de 75 ans elle est
importante dans le département et
pourquoi c'est la deuxième strate
peut-être de ceux de cette stratégie
vaccinale la population en effet âgé
quand même là celle qui est la plus
fragile a et on l'a vu chez celles qui
comportent le plus de décès donc au bois
pour protéger nos aînés parce que ce
sont eux qui agit depuis l'écran et les
lieux plus longue de décès dans les
yvelines qui tue en tête mais il ya il
est en effet une population qui est
grillagé le piètre ou commune les deux
chantiers jeunes on a le chiffre en tête
le sud est question c'était oui à
versailles
ça commence comme sur loeb et l'ensemble
des départements lundi prochain donc
aujourd'hui il ya il ya 4 4 centres de
vaccination qui sont le vital millions
tel centre quand le porteur ensuite il
ya les tables de poissy hôpital demande
est le pionnier sont ces établissements
qui aujourd'hui maxine les
professionnels de santé libéraux et
hospitaliers alors on n'en contient de
santé comme il le fera jeudi à la fois
les soignants et puis personne
démonstratif qui est aussi nécessaire au
bon fonctionnement des établissements
qui sont ceux qui ont une cinquantaine
d'idées comment douter
ensuite vous avez des établissements
privés comme ceux qui se drapent c'est
général de santé où ceux ci se la
clinique saint-louis gars apprécié
qu'ils vaccinent leur personnel soignant
la même façon et puis vous avez les
étals à partir de lundi il va y avoir
d'autres s'en trouvait hier autour de 5
ou 6 et ça c'est sûr c'est la grèce qui
va donner les noms ce soir demain qui
chevaux globalement aux agglomérations
différentes agglomérations des hippies
rassemblement 1 à versailles donc
reversée à grands pas 1 sur saint
quentin 1 au dessus de la scène un autre
en voilà un qui correspondent aux
différents tableaux
les versions positionner il ya
suffisamment de vaccins pour pouvoir
approvisionner on ne sait pas multiplier
non plus parce qu'il n'y a pas ces 10
des vaccins disponibles pour toutes les
communes etc
l'organisme bourg-des-comptes que ça
mais ce sont donc ces patients soit 140
points domicile et qui a activement est
vacciné parallèlement il y aller venez
le conseil départemental des yvelines
vaccine dans les structures d'autonomie
ce qu'on appelle les donc tout ce qui
est handicapé et donc le conseil de
l'ordre et la chose conduite et en
soutien
travaillant pour aujourd'hui avec le
docteur albert fernandez
et puis ces services l'excitation des
personnes
en situation de handicap qui sont dans
des foyers a effectivement aux deux
boucs et à l'ail est aussi un centre de
doses de vaccins qui sont là pour
protéger ces populations et on commence
de la même façon à partir de lundi à
vacciner dans ses chaussures là olivier
pajot vous de votre côté donc vous
peuvent vivalto santé est ce que vous
avez lettres peut-être amené avec ce
n'est hors des établissements vos
passions qu'elle est les prochaines
quelles sont les prochaines étapes chez
vous elle à la toute prochaine étape
c'est de d'amplifier la vaccination par
des soignants comme ça nous a été
recommandé dans la mesure de ce qui sera
recommandée nous on va suivre le tempo
qui est imposé par la rs il s'agit pas
évidemment de d'ajouter ou de créer la
confusion il faut être dans ce qui nous
est recommandée et puis effectivement
sans que l'on soit prédisposé à être un
centre de vaccination dans le territoire
à l'heure où je parle un nous on se
rendra disponible bien évidemment si si
nécessaire pour apporter notre aide soit
pour créer s'il le faut des centres de
vaccination soit pour participer parce
que dans un centre de vaccination a une
particularité il faut des vaccinés on
peut dire ça et donc un certain nombre
de personnels ce sujet la ville de
versailles rechercher des praticiens
pour pouvoir administrer les premiers
vaccins on va conclure cette émission
merci à tous les trois à d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation
si vous chers téléspectateurs vous
souhaitez suivre l'évolution de la
vaccination en france les chiffres sont
actualisés chaque soir à 19h30 depuis le
11 janvier dernier le site du ministère
de la santé s'affiche en bas de l'écran
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]